hey what's up this is john with the dr
john deloney show quick heads up for
those tuning in
today's show is adult themed man we've
got addiction challenges we've got
childhood safety and relationships and
so make sure
if young eyes or young ears are watching
or listening that you preview the show
first and we're also going to be talking
about parents
and grandparents who won't stop sending
end of times
political crazy electronic communication
to their kids
and what the kids can do about it stay
tuned
[Applause]
hey good folks i'm john and this is the
dr john delony show where i'm taking
your calls about your life as you work
live love and interact with people in
your
head in your home in your schools in
your neighborhood
everywhere everyone live
love that sounds like one of those
pinterest things that go up in your
living room right but whatever we're
talking about we're talking about
your relationships your relational iq
we're gonna talk about parenting
we're gonna talk about addiction we
might even talk about
that one dude you have in your life
that's dubbed themselves the grammar
police right when you're telling a story
and you're all into it and they stop you
like it's not me and my friends it's my
friends and i and you're just like
oh shut up we're talking about all of it
today right so if you want someone to
hear you
you want a second opinion worth about
what you're gonna pay for it
or anything i'm here to walk with you
right so give me a call at 1
1-844-693-3291
that's 1-844-693-3291
leave a message leave a detailed message
kelly will
check out your message leave your number
we should call you back and see if we
can get you scheduled for the show
if you're more comfortable emailing
email me at ask
john ramseysolutions.com ask john
ramseysolutions.com
leave your name your number and a brief
message
and we will get back in touch with you
so we're going to go right to the phones
um we're going to talk to john in
seattle john how we doing
honestly i'm tired man but i'm good oh
man i'm so grateful so
so listen before we get going i want to
talk directly to the audience here and
kind of let you know
about my conversation coming up here
with john um
the reality is john and i have already
recorded a conversation
together and it went about 20 minutes or
so maybe a little bit longer
and the short of it is i messed up the
call i didn't do a good job responding
i was wordy and verbose and most
importantly
i didn't pay attention to a couple of
key things and so i
used wrong language i used wrong terms
and i stumbled through
just my response was just poor right and
one of the reasons that i wanted to
talk to john again is what he has to
what is going on in his life is
important
but two i want to let everyone listening
to this show
no coaches aren't perfect
mentors aren't perfect counselors aren't
perfect the people in your life that you
entrust your
heart with your advice to man they
stumble and they mess up
and so i wanted to go first in this
exchange here and let everybody listen
to the show
john let you know man i'm sorry i didn't
do a good job the first time around
still getting used to this show how
everything works
and your situation was unique for me man
and
i want to let everybody know that it's
okay to give somebody else another shot
so john i'm really grateful for you
calling back
and let me have a mulligan on this one
brother
no i appreciate it and uh listen
yeah i'm a big fan of yours i respect
what you do
um and i value your opinion and i
i realize myself that i do need a little
bit of help and
uh you know i i appreciate it and i'm
i'm thankful for getting another shot to
talk to you well thank you so much so
let's
let's walk you back to the beginning
what's going on your life and how can i
help
yeah so um you know i'm in my late 40s
i like to consider myself a success uh i
have a very well-paying job thankfully
and i work a lot of hours like i did
yesterday about 16.
providing yeah i know and that's
every other day or so um and
but i uh i struggle uh for a long time
now
uh with an addiction to you know i guess
what i like to call webcam models
uh talking to a woman online
uh you know only online and just talking
erotically to them
uh you know
uh that's that's my addiction and i
spent a lot of money doing it
tell me about the money you've spent
tell me how much time talking about the
the what this is costing you
uh well i mean financially i mean tens
of thousands of dollars
um probably a year at least
um and that's probably being kind
and uh time i just find myself you know
when you know instead of reading a book
or working on a novel i
should be writing or something uh
you know i'm on the internet uh just
looking around on these websites for
probably a connection
and interaction you know that only lasts
you know 10 or 15 minutes um
but you know before you know it three
hours has gone by you know
and it's it's a time suck right and so
for those listening webcam girls
are really people on demand right so
they'll come into your
internet and your house or if you put on
your big screen tv they'll come in
and you can talk with them you pay by
the minute right
was it three to five three to six bucks
a minute something like that
and they'll basically do whatever you
ask them to do
over five minutes ten minutes two hours
is that am i
am i right there you're 100
right and the interesting thing it's
like in today's world of the internet
it's it's not just like it's actually
you know people would be surprised i
think by who these webcam models are
you know these are normal women who have
had regular jobs and now because of
coleman or whatever
they needed to make an extra income from
their home
you know they're single mothers they're
real people
which i think is what also makes it so
enticing you know
sure um you know so
you do feel like you have some type of
real connection to them
which i lack you know their job
their job is to make you feel connected
right like they're actresses their job
is to make you
feel loved appreciated
and more importantly to keep you on the
line as long as possible because every
minute is a is
another cha-ching cha-ching is that
right
uh overall yes you know uh i don't i
don't think they all
you know are you you know they're real
they realize you you know you gotta go
you gotta do things
but um but um that's what i'm saying but
just real people
which i think is what also makes it so
enticing you know it's not
it's not necessarily just a fantasy girl
you know that is completely unattainable
if that makes sense yeah absolutely so
last time we talked
we dug in a little bit to your past and
just to
for the sake of the time you don't come
from
a home of abuse you've got good parents
you've got a great job
you are somebody that your community
counts on and
is always with you when you step back
30 000 feet and you say i've got this
behavior that is costing me money it's
costing me time
where do you think this comes from what
are you hiding from
what vulnerability are you protecting
yourself from getting hurt
yeah um you know that's a good question
you know it's um
i don't know it you know it definitely
comes from
you know a long long time ago you know
uh
i used to read erotica um
and like that's when i was like in
college somehow i
started reading erotica and as
with a lot of addictions you know the
erotica
you know becomes a more heightened sense
of erotica and that's what you know when
things progressed you know it became
just calling
you know somebody on the phone you know
before the whole
you know webcaming the old the old one
900 numbers back in the day right
yeah and then that turned into oh you
could actually
see somebody's face um
so it goes back quite a long time well
over 20 years
um so what happened now that makes you
want to stop
doing this behavior
well a lot of it you know is financial
you know and yes i do make a good living
but i recognize
how much money i'm spending and i have
for a while and i don't know it like
maybe because i'm so close to being
debt-free
you know following you know your boss
dave ramsey as you alluded to last week
um it really bothers me how much money
i am you know i say wasting but wasting
you know and i have been in
relationships where i don't do it
you know i don't have the compulsion to
call
if i am in a relationship but i am not
often in a relationship
you know and that's probably a whole
other issue like
why can't i fall in love and be that
right person right
but what i do look for somebody
you know and this is the other reason i
think it inhibits
how i think of that person like
initially like i want to know oh
are they open-minded are they you know
for lack of a better word thinking
okay you know and and i think that's not
healthy
so one of the things that stuck in my
head the last time we talked and have
just kind of
bounced around like a bouncy ball in
there for the last
couple of days has been this idea
that i don't know or i haven't been
convinced by you john that
you want to stop this behavior or this
interaction
i understand that you don't like the
derivative effects you don't like a
smaller bank account
you don't like that it when you meet
somebody new your head immediately goes
to
i wonder how bizarre this person would
be or how
different this person would be or to not
use
normed words right i wonder if this
person shares my same
sexual identity i wonder if this person
is into the same things i'm into
and you miss the the human exchange
right just the high how are yous
and just the joys and ups and downs and
sadnesses
of just getting to know somebody i
didn't get a sense that that's something
you want to stop
webcam girls you just want these other
things do you really want to quit this
behavior
or do you just want to be debt free and
have a good relationship
and i hope you can see the difference of
my question there
yeah i mean i think there's a happy you
know yeah that's a good question
um i think there's a happy medium in a
way
you know i mean listen if i'm in a
relationship i do not feel
that i need
you know these women you know on the
internet
um but you know i do
feel or i've convinced myself that they
are giving me something
you know with you know decreasing my
anxiety before work
or um i do feel sometimes
it's you know necessary
um you know or i justify well i'm single
so it's okay
um so make mo make no mistake man they
are giving you something they are giving
you
release they are giving you connection
however
broken and crooked it is it's still
connection right it's still intimacy
and not true vulnerable human to human
intimacy but it is an intimate exchange
especially as you mentioned these aren't
models these aren't professionals these
are
run-of-the-mill folks normal folks from
our neighborhoods right trying to make
some extra money
um they are giving you an opportunity
to escape they are giving you an
opportunity to not live in the reality
that you're lonely
not live in the reality that for 20
years you've wanted this thing
and not living in the reality that
life is filled with complexion
and frustration and real relationships
take a lot of work and they are hard and
they're uncomfortable
they do give you all those things right
and so
what when you're coming up against an
addiction there's got to be a moment
when you say the pain of continuing this
addiction
is i want that gone more than the
benefit i'm getting from it and
and to be honest with you man i don't
hear that from you yet
i hear an annoyance and a frustration
not a
face in the dirt i have to be done with
this
and for a 20-year addiction i think
that's where you've got to be i think
you can't casually
or um sort of or happy medium your way
out of this situation or you got to find
somebody who's going to be a partner
with you that's going to be
into it too when that's it's that's a
whole other phone call right
but it doesn't sound like you're at a
place where i just i'm i've got to be
finished with this
am i wrong there um
i don't know that's a good question
that's a good question i know i keep
saying that but
it's um i think by reaching out to you
and putting you know this to air to
whoever hears it
i'm pretty close to that okay um you
know i feel very vulnerable
yeah uh i mean uh pardon me
far to be wanted to call also because i
appreciate all the people who call about
other things
that a lot of people don't talk about
and
uh i know i know a lot of people have
this type of thing and
and i thought it was important also for
them to hear
who hears this you know about you know
this type of addiction but
um i do feel
you're you're right i mean because i
deal with alcoholics and i i haven't hit
rock bottom
you know in that way and uh
you know i think because i do make a
good living
it's almost in a way preventing me from
hitting rock bottom
because i haven't lost you know
my family my home alienated you know
personal relationships in my life
and that's a common challenge with
functional recreational drug users right
as it begins to slowly take over
everything if you are excellent at your
job you do make a good living you can
buy yourself
years of punting that challenge down the
road before it comes and gets you right
so here's the thing i want to address a
couple of things and i even brought some
notes this time
um i think it's important for everyone
listening to this
an addiction to webcam girls an
addiction to
what i would call a sexualized addiction
where you are
numbing the challenges and the
frustrations and the fears of real
relationships and you're trading that
for um really i guess the old joke is
the oldest job on planet earth
right which is sex in exchange for money
um i want everyone to hear that that's
sensationalized right
this is a real challenge in a real
person's life but most of us
don't walk through our lives struggling
with an addiction
to webcam girls but i don't want a
listener to this podcast to give
themself a pass
on the idea that addiction is addiction
is addiction as a culture if you look at
what's happening in covid
we are drinking too much we are drink i
heard 300 times
alcohol sales are up working too much is
is an addiction sexual infidelity
purchasing things
buying things just getting that quick
dopamine hit when you click through
amazon
working out too much being addicted to
measuring your macros and micros on your
this as a culture
we will do anything to not feel the pain
and frustration and exhaustion of just
everyday living
and so while john why your thing is out
there right it's sensationalized and
it's webcam girls
and millions of people listen to this
are going to go
whoa i don't even know that exists or
i've never even heard of that or i just
read about that once
i don't want people to give themselves a
pass right so addiction as addiction is
addiction
the second thing is i if you actually
want to
want to solve this problem right and
again i'm not
super convinced that you're fully in
there john but if you do
i want you to do two things number one i
want you to pick up
a book by gabor mate called in the realm
of hungry ghosts
it's the single greatest book on
addiction i've ever read
i know there's probably a million other
ones but it's a book that really spoke
to me
as an author gabor dr mate speaks to my
heart in several ways but
it's a book on addiction and it walks
through
the the the path that people take to get
where they are
i also want you to pick up a book by
terence real called i don't want to talk
about it
it's the secret legacy of male
depression and folks men especially who
get wrapped up in
sexualized addictions or addictions of
power or addictions of disconnection
they just go off into another place and
then you find yourself out in the woods
somewhere and you don't know the path to
get back
so those are two important books i also
want to just i can't say this strongly
enough
you cannot get through addiction you
cannot
change your life behavior particularly
one of 20 years
by yourself you're going to have to get
into
a sexaholics anonymous group you're
going to have to get into
a 12-step group of some sort you're
going to have to get with a local church
or a local community group you're going
to have to get to some group
and i'm going to recommend if your
addiction is on the internet
if your addiction is online that that's
not a good place to find community and i
know that stinks especially now in covid
man that just sucks but
going online logging in that whole thing
is gonna kick in a trigger and that's
going to start
the compulsion process dr mate in his
book
he talks about five quick things and
i'll run through him real quick
he talks about when you have these urges
remember that this is not a broken brain
you don't have a disease you've got a
disordered brain a malfunctioning brain
that is trying to compensate for
a lack of stability a lack of
vulnerable relationships a lack of
identity right
and so what you're trying to do when you
when you change your
thoughts and your actions out of an
addictive behavior
you're really trying to heal and
transform a malfunctioning brain he says
so here's the five steps he gives you
number one you have to re-label
thoughts and urges right you don't need
to eat that junk or withdraw
but you've got to stop yourself as these
urges come right
um you may have a feeling this urgency
you know john talks about this
this feeling of urgency this compulsion
but there's actually nothing urgent
going on and so you have to relabel
those
those feelings as things i have to do to
okay now i've got to ask myself a hard
question what's my
brain trying to protect me from is it
the stress of going to this busy job
that john has
is it this this frustration this i need
to get this release before i go to work
so i can be calm
it's this impending anxiety
whatever this this feeling this
compulsion is number two you have to
re-attribute it
to something else right you've got to
reattribute it
towards from these things that happen to
you or this bad behavior or here comes
my compulsion again i'm feeling myself
want to log in stop stop
dumping a bunch of garbage onto those
thoughts and just re-attribute them to
man what's my brain trying to protect me
from anytime you're about to buy
something
smoke something drink something text
that old girlfriend
anytime you are about to go back to the
gym for a second time
ask yourself what is my brain trying to
protect me from
and then you can even get to a place
through mindfulness of that where you
think your brain
you say thanks brain i appreciate you
taking care of me the third thing is you
got to refocus and i know this sounds
cheesy or lame
but you have to decide in that moment
when you feel that compulsion and you
re-label it to
thanks brain for taking care of me you
have to then choose to go
do something else that's in 12-step
programs you call your sponsor
in weight loss programs you go outside
of your home and you go for a walk
right whatever it may be is you're
starting to
refocus and teach your brain that it
doesn't have to obey
as dr mate says it doesn't have to obey
the urgency call
the fourth thing is is you have to
revalue
and he suggests it's called d-value
right
but this is just to really drive into
your head
that the real impact of this urge
is disaster it is
tens of thousands the last time john and
i talked
about a hundred thousand dollars he
spent on webcam girls
at some point somebody at work is gonna
find out
somebody's gonna release the footage of
the webcams
somebody's to put something out there
somebody's going to look at your
receipts and see
just how much you've been drinking or
you're going to miss a ball game or
you're going to drive drunk or
any number of things that are on the
back of addictive behaviors
you've got to re-value it and understand
that
this only leads to disaster it's gonna
feel good right now it's gonna give me
release
this ends in a train wreck and then
you've got to recreate this is the final
one
you've got values you've got passions
you've got talents capabilities he says
but you have to recreate you've got to
recreate
new relationships new default settings
new behaviors
and that ultimately your brain will
begin to when it
instead of feeling that compulsion to
log into a webcam girl to go have
something to drink to get on amazon and
buy something to just sit in front of
netflix and mindlessly scroll
it will say we need to go for a walk we
need to go
hug my wife i've got to take my kids and
go hold both with their hands and we're
going to go out into the woods in the
rain
whatever it is but your brain will
recreate new paths
that you can follow so again i want to i
want to thank john for
number one for giving me a mulligan on
this one i want to thank him for being
vulnerable
and take taking something out of the
darkness that people struggle with
whether it's pornography whether it's
sexual addiction infidelity whatever it
is
webcam girls and broadly
announcing to the world hey i struggle
with this and i've been struggling for a
couple of decades
i also want to encourage john and
everybody listening
find people in your life that you can be
vulnerable and open with
that's the only path to true recovery
from addiction
and then check out dr mate's book these
five values are in that book
and it was a transformative experience
for me reading that book
it looks at how we treat addicts in this
culture how criminalization it talks
about all of it right so it's a good
place for you to start so
um we took a little bit longer with that
call and with this idea of addiction so
again i want to thank john
and thank you all for listening let's go
back to the phones let's talk to
marcus in seattle marcus how are we
doing good man
doing great helping yourself good hey
first and foremost um
how's how's the fires going are you and
your family safe y'all doing okay
yeah we're doing fine uh we got some
rain last night yeah it looks like it
cleared up the smoke a little bit
oh that's fantastic what a blessing well
marcus how can i help good man
so um i have a question how do i break
the family cycle of behavior
how do i convince my daughters to get
counseling when they do not want to talk
to a counselor my daughters are
10 and 12. a little back story
i'm active active duty of 14 years i've
been going through a divorce process for
almost a year and a half
and i was awarded full custody of my
girls in march
during the divorce process my ex was
ordered to get a psyched out
it came back with an intermittent
explosive disorder and paranoid
personality
there are other behavior issues on my
exercise of the family
that i'm concerned with my ex has a set
of twins with someone else
and she is called my youngest the
youngest daughter or traitor
screamed at my oldest daughter because
she didn't get the response she was
expecting
and she claimed that my daughters are
not mine and
i believe that they are my girls she's
throwing
baby bottles at me full of
water spit in my face assaulted me i
caught her on video and turned it into
the police
and she's facing domestic violence
charges
she has claimed mental disorder in her
defense
and now we're waiting on her to get
evaluated for the trial she went to ncis
and claimed that i sexually assaulted
her
nine months after our last sexual
encounter
also she went to a navy organization and
claimed that
the girls were harming themselves but
has no evidence to support the claim
she has a history of control issues
where she's not in control of the
situation she becomes out of control
all right hey marcus marcus yes
you've told me a lot about her tell me a
lot about you
as you've been talking it sounds like
you're a broken exhausted
ex-husband and you're a broken exhausted
dad
am i right yeah
do you love those two girls nearly
and then and then with uh covid
and having to deal with homeschool all
the time
yeah thankfully my uh
my command has worked with me so i can
be here during the day when
when they need me most but you know this
is the
hardest thing i forgot to go through
yeah
so marcus i want to tell you a couple of
things number one just
dad to dad i love you and i am grateful
for you and i'm proud of you okay
because what you're going through is a
nightmare nothing
gets in a dad's soul like somebody
messing with his girls
and i know that that's their mom i know
that that's your wife
and normally i'm pretty protective of
ex-parents but this sounds like a
situation that is
about their safety their physical safety
their psychological safety their
spiritual safety
and so i want to reiterate you're doing
the right things
i know that it's a
defcon two pain when somebody reports
something to your administrative
structures and ncis and those crews have
to go through the rigamaroo
that's such a beating and they want all
your texts and emails i know that just
sucks man
and so just the exhaustion of it i want
to hear you
and say this sucks this sucks and i'm
sorry
um a couple of things
that i want to put out there for you and
then
direct you to a few places number one
your daughters are 12 and 10
they don't get a choice yeah
they have to um everything that they
know to
about relationships they learn from
their mother and from their dad
and you know this with just
forgetting the diagnostics here they did
not pick that up from mom
and they are going to have to have
they're going to have a a significant
learning curve and a relearning curve
this counseling i'm going to recommend
you all do it together for the
foreseeable future
because they're going to have to learn
with the help of a neutral
third party and with you involved how to
have a real relationship
and my guess is right now broadly they
don't know how to do that
they've got a dad who is going to war
for them literally and figuratively
as a 10 and 12 year old they don't
understand that yet right
they don't get they will circle back and
realize oh my gosh my dad
what an incredible man they're just 12
and 10 they don't get that right
and so what you want to do with family
counseling right now is to help them
turn those alarms down
to turn those off and or at least quiet
them it's going to be hard as long as
mom
is continuing to be a part of their
their lives
and i'm going to tell you something
marcus i don't normally tell folks
you told me you got full custody is that
right yes
so you're going to have to be pretty
protective of them and
their interactions with their mom
because mom's not safe
mom's not right now she's limited down
to text messaging
because of her conduct and i would i
would
be relentless i wouldn't give my 10 and
12 year old a phone i've got a 10 year
old and he doesn't know how to turn on a
phone to save his life
i'm i'm i'm kind of a lunatic about that
kind of stuff but
i would be relentless about checking
their phones checking their
communication
because as she as your daughters get to
be 14 15 and 16 and they're gonna be
desperate for
a womanly presence in their life mom's
gonna
transform to this cool hip friend right
is gonna turn into this person that
dad's not right
and so i would be just relentless
just relentless and be over
attuned to things like physical touch
make sure you're hugging your daughters
you're holding their hands you're
looking them in the
eye that you come home turn all your
electronics off and make them the center
of the universe
for a while and i know that's hard it's
not convenient that's
mind-numbing and frustrating but man
you're in it and i wish
i could tell you otherwise more than
anybody in the world
as a as a soldier you know there's just
moments when man we're just getting
shelled and this is just
this is it and you're in that season
with these girls
and i can hear in your heart that you
love them and i can also hear that
you're
exhausted so here's my question for you
do you have a place where you can go be
well
or you can get a break where you can put
your oxygen mask on
um not really because uh
in the mornings i'm here with the girls
and then and the
uh you know i go to work in the
afternoons
so all right so marcus uh marcus
you are worth being well brother yep
and you are worth getting a good night's
sleep
you were worth eating okay you're worth
working out a few times a week
you're worth falling in love with again
and if you don't take care of yourself
you know this it's
you're gonna end up face down in the mud
yep okay and i don't know what that
looks like for you
i'm i'm talking from a uh i'm with you
is what i'm saying
when people in my life are hurting my
self-care goes out the window and we
just have to remember that old thing
from the airplane pilots that
if we lose cabin pressure we got to put
our mask on first or everyone in the
in our road dies all right well i am
lucky i do have someone in my life
okay so that uh that i have found so
that
good she has been a lifeline good um
so when it when it comes to talking um
to your daughters
you're gonna have to walk a a balance
and i'm gonna recommend you don't bad
mouth mom
you don't talk bad about her being crazy
or she's this that
i would let your daughters know that
mommy's sick mommy's sick
and she's not doing well and daddy
loves them more than life
itself daddy loves them
more than they will ever understand and
the older they get
the more fun stuff you all do the more
connected y'all do
maybe y'all keep a letter writing
journal where it's a spiral notebook
you have with each each daughter and her
job is to write you a note every day
and when they go to bed you'll read it
and respond to it or you'll wake up
early in the morning don't read those at
night time because sometimes it'll be
pretty dark
but wake up in the morning and respond
to them and let them know that you love
them but it's going to give them
something tangible they can hold on to
and make sure you are taking care of
yourself but going back to your original
question
12 year olds 10 year olds they don't get
a vote on whether they want to go to
counseling or not
especially in this situation they will
go
you will all go this is something that
you are going to be in for the long haul
and i'm not a fan of going to counseling
forever this is something you're going
to have to invest in because your
daughters are going to have to relearn
and i say relearn we think about
knowledge right we think about our
frontal lobes i'm not talking about that
right now i'm talking about our
amygdalas
they're going to have to learn their
bodies are going to have to learn how to
whoo how to relax how to breathe
and how to be in relationship with other
people and they're probably gonna
struggle with this for a while
thank god they've got a dad who loves
them more than life itself
thank you for your service to our
country
equally as important if not more thank
you for being a dad who gives a crap
marcus there's too many parents who
don't care
who write their kids off god bless you
man for being
in the fight with for your daughters um
ah what a gift what a saint brother
thank you so much for your call
and we'll be thinking i'm praying of you
i want you to give me a call back marcus
i want you to give this four or five
months i want you to give me a call back
let me know how things are going let me
know how counseling is going let me know
how your
intentional connection with your
daughters
eye contact daily journals together
prayer time together
working out together whatever that looks
like i want you to know i want you to
call me back and let me know how things
are going
um i'll be thinking about you all right
let's go to one more call let's go to
kevin
in los angeles kevin what is up
oh you know uh trapped inside due to
quarantine and now there's smoke
everywhere so
man you folks in california are compared
to the last
compared to the last phone call i am
doing fantastic that definitely put
things in perspective
well hey listen we don't do a grief
comparing here so
you're allowed to know have a sucky
sucky week too man
um we are just praying and thinking for
you folks in california that's just a
nightmare on top of a nightmare on top
of a nightmare on top of
man your housing's expensive it all kind
of sucks right now doesn't it
yeah but somewhat i mean honestly life
is pretty good compared to
uh you said not to compare there we go
all right
life is good 2019 life was better yeah
all right kevin so how can i help you
man um
so one of the things i wanted to ask
about was
um my mom and my grandma keep sharing
political videos and articles
often dozens of times a day and most of
it looks like propaganda to me
um without telling them i actually
unfollowed both of them on social media
just because they were stressing me out
with all the stuff they were putting
forward
and then they started just directly
messaging me
like all these things all these videos
about like it's going to be the end of
america
if x gets elected or y is trying to rig
the election this that or the other
and i talked to my mom and said hey um
this stuff stresses me out
could you please stop sending it to me
and she responded
well i just want you to know what to
pray for and i feel like both
she and my grandma are using the excuse
of prayer to kind of fall down a
political rabbit hole
so would you say it's disrespectful for
me to just
ignore the messages which is kind of
what i'm doing right now
or should i try to convince them that
what they're doing is unhealthy
oh man that's a lot there so i'm gonna
run through this relatively quick are
you ready kevin
yes number one you named one of my pet
peeves brother
which is people who use prayer
who use mindfulness who use this this
shroud of love and care
to spread gossip about people
right we've seen these people at church
or like i don't want to gossip but you
know what susie's been up to right
um we need to pray for billy because
he's about to go to jail right it's just
a way to
to snake your way into a conversation
that really at the root of it is about
disparaging people i can't stand that
right
um so number two dude um
you've done the noble thing which is to
have the conversation
my recommendation is to have it one more
time and
maybe even via email so they can have it
in writing and they can go back to it
and here's why
when somebody's amygdala is engaged when
the stress center or
fear center of their brain is on fire
they cannot be reasoned with right and
our brains
work that way on purpose they don't want
us looking at the entrance of a cave and
being like
is that a nice bear or a gentle bear
maybe that's a mean bear
our brains just are designed to say run
dude there's a bear we'll figure out if
he's nice
later we're out and so when we have
people in our lives
and we all do brother kevin who are
convinced that this is the end of time
this is it we things are up that if
president a is elected we're all going
to be okay if president b is elected
it's we're all going to die we are going
to die and there are hurricanes in the
gulf
two of them just landed at the same time
the west coast is on fire
fill in the blank it's all a struggle
right now
when we have folks in our life like that
just sitting down and trying to talk
facts and sense is not helpful it's just
not
and so yes at some point after you draw
that boundary and say
i'm asking you all to stop i'm going to
continue to pray for our country i'm
going to
pray for our family i'm going to pray
for everybody i don't need the details
anymore
if they do it after that then yes you
got to ignore it you got to cut them off
you got to block them
you can tell your mom i'm going to call
you but i've asked you to stop sending
me this stuff and you continue to do it
and i know it's a hard conversation to
have but it is a bold adult conversation
and my promise is she loves you more
than the drama and i think she'll come
around kevin
you sound like a wise young man why is
beyond
many of our of the folks i run with
um who just let our parents bombard us
with some of this stuff in our and our
kids and our friends and co-workers
but yeah draw boundaries and then if
people violate those boundaries
you have every right every every
responsibility to yourself and those who
love you to say i'm i'm out i'm not
going to respond to this nonsense i'm
going to block your phone call i'll call
you if i need something
for sure block people on social media
and whatnot but i think the the proper
way to do this is to write an email to
your mom
and your grandma and say i am praying
for our country i love things
this type of information i'm not
interested anymore i don't want to see
it anymore
please do not send it to me anymore and
kevin i've had those conversations in my
life and the folks that
know me and love me have respected those
boundaries and so
man i appreciate the call i know that so
many people across the country
millions are dealing with this exact
thing
and here's the deal at the end of this
election regardless of who's elected
and who ends up in washington who's not
whatever
i'm still gonna have to go to starbucks
and see the waitress
see the person at the counter i'm still
going to pump gas next to you
in your car i'm still going to see you
at the grocery store
i'm still going to email back and forth
to you at work
at the end of the day our relationships
with one another is all that matters
washington has never
my problems are not going to be solved
in washington good folks my problems are
going to be solved locally
in my neighborhood in my office in my
heart
i believe that strongly and i want to
encourage everybody to begin to
open back up your relationships around
you with your loved ones and respect
each other's boundaries
all right so that wraps up today's show
we're going to end the lyrics of the day
listen the last couple of weeks as this
show has launched i've said this is the
greatest ever since greatest ever
i haven't been telling the truth this is
the greatest album of all time
and on this album is the greatest song
of all time
it's a 1987 album by the band u2
it's the joshua tree record and the song
that has burrowed its way into hearts of
millions of people across the world
is where the streets have no name and it
goes like this
i want to run i want to hide i want to
tear
down the walls that hold me inside i
want to reach out
and touch the flame where the streets
have no name
i want to feel sunlight on my face i see
the dust cloud
disappear without a trace i want to take
shelter from the poison
reign where the streets have no name
this is the dr john dolone's show